today on the matt welsh show two white
students are kicked out of a study hall
at arizona state university for the
crime of being white also a couple of
afghans we evacuated from the country in
august have already been charged with
sex crimes and a mother at a school
board meeting confronts the school board
over the heinous and pornographic books
that are being distributed to students
in the district will play that clip for
you plus australian police are now
firing rubber bullets indiscriminately
into crowds of protesters and finally a
woman on the subway is offended by
pornographic okay cupid ads so she takes
matters into her own hands heroically i
think all of that and more today on the
matt walsh show
[Music]
now we check in with our friends over at
40 days for life when the topic of
abortion comes up it's easy to get
nervous which it's certainly in the last
few weeks it's probably come up in your
life
uh plenty of times but maybe you get
nervous it's a charged topic and when
you're talking to
friends or family or co-workers
and especially if you if you don't know
exactly what to say and if you're not
prepared for all of the arguments and
objections that may be thrown at you
then that's when
it can be bad and that's why one of the
reasons why i wrote the forward to the
new book what to say when the complete
new guide to discussing abortion which
became an amazon bestseller and number
one in its category upon its release two
weeks ago it's an easy book to use tells
you what to say and what not to say when
abortion comes up it has proven
arguments that have worked with
everybody people on the fence abortion
supporters even planned parenthood
workers if you want to know how good the
arguments are well 40 days for life has
helped to convert the hearts and minds
of 221 abortion clinic workers that's
how effective it is this is an
invaluable tool and a timely tool as
well so get it now what to say when the
complete new guide to discussing
abortion how to change minds and convert
hearts in a brave new world go to amazon
or get it directly from 40 days for life
at 40daysforlife.com
we begin today with a viral video from
the campus of arizona state university
the most shocking thing in this footage
is that it's not shocking at all it
ought to be
instead this is exactly what we've come
to expect from college campuses in the
video two white males are sitting at a
table doing schoolwork
they're approached by two female
students both non-white
who inform them that they have to leave
the room because they're white also
because one of them has a police lives
matter sticker on his laptop and his
friends sitting across the table is uh
wearing a shirt that says did not vote
for biden
which i can see why you want that on a
shirt it is something to be proud of
they but they weren't standing on the
table and screaming
these messages they were rather sitting
at an otherwise empty table minding
their own business causing no disruption
of any kind when they were accosted by
the two racist women of course those
women felt themselves so justified or so
sure of their own righteousness
that they're the ones who recorded and
posted this exchange
part of their grievance as you'll hear
in the footage is that the study hall
the area where they are
sitting um
according to the women is a
multicultural space
now even if that's true you'd think the
word multi would cover the white men but
apparently not so here's what happened
watch
should i do wrong
you have it you're you're offensive
police lives matter
but this is our space
we've got a police lives matter sticker
and we're getting kicked out can't do
school
nobody's thinking
you just said we have to leave no i said
you're making the space uncomfortable
you're uncomfortable
but you're white do you understand what
a multicultural space it means you're
not being centered white's not a culture
no no it's not a culture it's white it's
not a culture say it again to the camera
you think whiteness is a culture
this is insane so anyways this is the
violence that asu does and this is the
type of people that they protect okay
this white man thinks he can take up our
space and this is why we need a
multicultural space because they think
they can get away with this
i'm going to sit here the whole time and
you can find somebody to get that that's
cool
we're asking you to leave if you have
any consideration for people of color
and marginalized they're clearly there
yeah the whole rest of the campus the
whole the second floor the first floor
the whole mu every single part of the
campus centers you this is the only
space that you're not centered and
you're still trying to center yourself
which is peak white cis male 1
you are racist your sticker is racist
because police that's a job you can
choose to be a police i didn't i don't
choose to be black
you know every time you you uh watch a
video with with one of these people you
hear
the language that they use
and uh they always use
these certain words certain language
that they use it where the cultish
aspect of this really comes through
so they're saying they're saying things
that make sense in the cult
but they don't even realize that this
doesn't mean anything to anyone outside
the cult so they're saying things like
you're not centered
this isn't a place where you're centered
what what the hell are you talking about
this is a this is a religious cult it's
it's very similar to
um you know you go to a certain church
or you're around people of a
you know a certain denomination
and they're going to speak in certain
ways and use certain lingo and use
certain words
that are familiar to them and that's
that's common in religions
and the point is that this is a religion
but what she says about police officers
uh they choose to be police officers
yeah that's true people choose to be
police officers
but why does that make police lives
matter and unnecessary much less a
racist sentiment
on the contrary police lives matter is a
far more important and necessary slogan
because there are plenty of people who
think that police lives don't matter
police lives matter is asserted in
response to the opposite view which many
people like the ones filming actually
hold
but who is black lives matter responding
to i mean everybody knows that black
lives matter nobody disagrees
the only people who disagree are the
violent criminals in the city most of
them black who murder black people every
day
although of course they don't recognize
the value in any human life at all they
target black people their own race most
of the time because those are the
victims closest at hand so so there
really is no prominent belief anywhere
in the country that black lives don't
matter
that makes the statement black lives
matter unnecessary which leads to the
suspicion that the person asserting it
really means something else
and very often they do
there is a silent but assumed
only or first and foremost that goes
before the statement black lives matter
meanwhile police lives matter and even
all lives matter are urgent and vital
messages precisely because there is
no such widespread agreement
on that point
in any case getting back to the video
this this exchange would go on for
several minutes
eventually the two guys did get up and
leave which is unfortunate
and we'll dissect the altercation in
more detail in a moment but before we do
that a little more background on the
racist shrews behind the camera they're
part of what they call the multicultural
solidarity coalition
yes a lot a lot of irony in that the
word solidarity there that's what that's
what solidarity looks like to them
solidarity is get up and get out of here
on their instagram page they explain um
how this room that they're in
was allegedly given to them by the
university listen
what's good y'all so
we're here uh with the multicultural
solidarity coalition and uh for over a
year they had us in these meetings over
and over and over again um
and all the out of the meeting they took
our 25 page proposal where we asked for
a three-story building which the student
pavilion will do okay
but uh
what they did in response to that is
give us a single room this is the room
that they gave us now you know
uh while the size you know it's okay
it'll take your whole floor but um
you know um
it's about care and intentionality and
what you see is they haven't even
changed the plaque
they haven't even changed the plaque so
why were we in meetings
every single week
and you can't change a plaque
didn't even change the plaque i mean the
the persecution and oppression that
these two poor girls are suffering is
really
really uh really really horrible pretty
unbelievable
i mean they're so persecuted and
uh oppressed
that they can harass two white guys on
the basis of their race and tell them to
leave the room
and they're not going to suffer any
consequences for it
and i i don't need to say it but of
course i am going to say it
that if we were to
change the racial demographics here
switch them around
and play out this same scene again
you know where it's the guys saying to
the girls you need to leave
and they ask why and the guys say well
you're black
i mean you can't even you can't imagine
the response to that these these guys
they'd be arrested on hate crime charges
this would be national news everywhere
so on and so forth
but these girls you know they are quite
reasonable on second thought they wrote
a long list of demands 25 pages long
including a demand for an entire
three-story building that they could
have for themselves but but they're
generously willing to accept a
compromise of just one room you know a
room from multicultural solidarity
is a is asu are they going to be giving
white students a room for white
solidarity somehow i doubt it
though really that shouldn't be
necessary why can't white students go
into the multicultural room and take
part in this solidarity well as the girl
explains white people don't have a
culture we don't get to have a culture
and that means we don't get to have our
own room or even to share their room
now
is it true
this is kind of interesting question
is it true that white people don't have
a culture
the race baiters on the other side seem
to waffle on this point one minute they
tell us that we have no culture the next
day tell us that we do have a culture
and the hallmarks of that culture are
white supremacy racism patriarchy
chauvinism etc
the answer as far as they're concerned
is that whites are allowed to have a
culture whenever it is convenient to
them to the race-baiters for us to have
one the truth has always changes
according to the needs of the moment
what is the reality though
well let's start with defining our terms
as i like to do
i think i think it would be fair to
define culture as the traditions
arts social institutions customs
accomplishments and heritage of a
particular group of people
we could all agree that's what a culture
is
do white people as a group
share traditions heritage social
institutions and so on well it's hard to
say we do because white is a broad
category that encompasses people from
dozens of different countries all across
the world
then again the same can be said for
black
that is also a broad category
encompassing many millions of disparate
people from many different countries and
regions of the globe
that means that if you want to refer to
culture in a meaningful way
i mean you could broaden it so much that
it doesn't mean i mean you could talk
about human culture
and talk about the most basic basic
things that all humans have in common
but when you're using it on a
on a
in a way that's as broad as that it just
it ceases to have any meaning so if you
want to talk about culture in a
meaningful way
you have to be more specific
if i wanted to talk about my
um heritage i would talk about my
ancestors who came from ireland
that's a cultural heritage though i'm
very far removed from it i've never even
visited ireland
really then what we should be concerned
about
is american culture
you know when someone asks me as a white
person
what's your culture i should be able to
say well what do you mean i'm american i
my american culture is my culture
i should be able to say that i can't say
that i'm a part of irish culture
i don't want to say that
i want to say that i am a member of and
a participant in
american culture
because i am american
and america indeed used to have a
culture but today that has been taken
over by something that could more
accurately be described as and has been
described as
an anti-culture
the women in that video as far left
activists are part of the anti-culture
the anti-culture destroys customs and
traditions
tears down the statues erases history
tries to sever people from their
heritage
if white people in america today don't
have a culture
it's because the very forces that accuse
them of not having a culture
have intentionally destroyed the culture
of which they were once apart
they rip up the history books and
demolish the monuments and close the
churches and decimate the culture and
then they turn to us tauntingly and say
where's your culture now huh
so it's true that white people in
america as a group don't have a culture
neither do black people in america
nobody in this country has a real
culture anymore because it's been ripped
to shreds by the forces of the
anti-culture
the culture war that we talk about
very important understand this
it is not a war between competing
cultures
it's not even a war for control of the
one culture
it is a war between a culture
and its negation
the left never has a legitimate
replacement for the things that it
destroys
just as it has never has a new
definition
for a word after it removes the old
definition
we've seen this many times
oh what is marriage well it's not what
you thought it was for for for
generations and generations and
centuries and millennia it's not that
anymore
it's it's not a a bond between a a man
and a woman
well then what is it well i don't know
it's anything
what is a woman well it's not an adult
human female well then what is it well i
don't know nothing
see as nihilus
they wish to take things away
and replace them with nothing
that's the goal
that's what they do with words and
that's what they're doing with the
culture take it away and replace it with
nothing
but this is all academic i mean the
women in that video they're not thinking
through any of this all they know is
that these two white boys have dared to
sit in their space
and to do so while advertising
viewpoints that they disagree with
that's why you know it was fruitless for
the two guys to engage and respond the
way they were i don't want a monday
morning quarterback it too much the
victims in this case were simply trying
to do their schoolwork they weren't
interested or looking to get involved in
this kind of exchange and they weren't
prepared for it and i understand that
but these days unfortunately you have to
be prepared for this kind of thing
especially on a college campus if you
make the tragic mistake of enrolling in
college to begin with
which is why it bears repeating again
that
when confronted with blabbering racist
clowns like those two girls
who are getting in your face and calling
you racist
even while
demonstrating the very racism they
accuse you of
there's no point in engaging with their
arguments or answering the charges they
make against you
the one guy repeatedly assures the girls
that no i'm not a racist
yet the more you deny it
the more you affirm the accusation in
their minds
and who cares what's what's in their
minds anyway
they're mostly empty minds the only
appropriate response in this situation
is to look them dead in the eyes and say
i don't care what you think
i don't care that you're offended
i don't care if you think i'm a racist
i don't care about your feelings
i apologize for nothing
now piss off and get out of my face
let them spin and twirl and work
themselves into a tissy over tizzy over
it let them do that
that's their problem
that's the only response
that works anymore
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know what i hate more than anything
in the world
and it's a long list
going to the auto parts store you know i
hate it because i tell you about it so
often some would say i even have an
unreasonable
hatred for the auto parts store but it
just it makes me seething
i seethe with rage as i walk through the
aisles of the auto parts store knowing
that i'm wasting my time and they won't
find they won't have the selection that
i need or the prices that i want and
then i start screaming that and i run
out
that's why it's so much better to go to
rockauto.com
a lot easier than going to the store a
lot cheaper and quicker too rockauto.com
always offers the lowest prices possible
and they're a family business as well
they've been serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years go to
rockauto.com now to shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers the catalog is unique and
extremely easy to navigate you can see
all the parts available
for your vehicle you can also just
easily plug in the brands the
specifications the prices you prefer you
just put all that in and it comes back
with exactly what you're looking for
every time and whatever price you get on
rockauto.com you know it's the best
price you're going to get so go to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car truck and wright
walsh and there how did you hear about
us box so they know that we sent you
so uh
next week september 28th i've told you
about the rally that um i'll be a part
of
the at the loudoun county school board
and that's going to be a 21 000
education court ashburn virginia
and if you go to my twitter or my
facebook you'll find out there's a an
event page that i we we link to which
has all the information but that's all
you really need to know 21000 education
court ashburn virginia we're going to be
rallying
um against the abuse and indoctrination
of kids in loudoun county and but but
that is also happening all across the
country
specifically the radical
trans policy they've put in place
opening up bathrooms opening up locker
rooms
you know letting boys into the girls
locker room girls sports teams requiring
teachers to use preferred pronouns upon
penalty of probably getting fired or
suspended as at least one teacher
already has been
and and not even for quote misgendering
a student in the classroom but but
simply for giving his opinion at a
school board meeting
and this again there's kind of things
happening all across the country but um
but
if we want to do something about it
you know we can we can make the general
sort of arguments which i do every day
but then we've also got to be there on
the ground
engaging with these things on a local
level which is what we're gonna do and
it's why we're rallying now
originally the plan was and uh if you
heard me advertising this rally
you know earlier in the week or last
week i said that the rally's gonna be a
five at um
at uh at five o'clock
and
and then the school board meeting was
the public comments and the school
buildings were supposed to be at 6 30.
so we'd have the rally and then people
are going to go in and and give their
opinions at the school board meeting
well the school board has
started
playing games here and so the first
thing they did is they moved their the
actual public comments up to when our
rally was supposed to start
i guess hoping that all the people that
would be criticizing them during the
public comments would be out in the
rally and wouldn't come in
and so we responded to that and we have
now moved um
the time of the rally up to four o'clock
so the rally's gonna start now at four
o'clock eastern we're gonna have the
rally for an hour and then you could go
into the public comments and the next
thing they did
and i have been told that this is a this
is a new rule change for the loudoun
county school board
because in the past
just like the school board i went to
here in nashville um the metro nashville
school board
all you had to do is you sign up ahead
of time
and anyone can go and give public
comments
it is after all a this is not a private
school we're talking about public this
is this is public
we're all taxpayers
anybody should have the right to show up
and and express their point of view
these school board
officials your school board members
they are public employees
so anyone should have the right
to show up and express their point of
view
but
as a
very coincidentally
of just mere days before i'm supposed to
show up there the loudoun county school
board has changed its rules
and i'm being told they've done this
basically illegally there's a process
for changing the rules for public
comment they have not followed the
process
in fact they're supposed to allow public
comment on the rule changes ahead of
time they're not doing that they've
changed the rules and now they're saying
that um
the only members of the public eligible
to address the school board now are
residents of loudoun county owners of
businesses located in loudoun county
or students parents or employees
in loudoun county those are the only
people who are eligible
and in order to address you got to show
up um here's what i got if someone sent
an email
um in order to give public comment at
the loudoun county school board meeting
you would need
either a valid virginia driver's license
indicating loudoun county residency
or a utility bill from 2021 with your
name and address
or a mortgage or lease agreement
or you could show your student report
card or employee id
i can tell you right now
that the people on the school board who
made this rule change
if if there were rules like that in
virginia to vote
they would tell you that it's racist and
oppressive so
you know they they want there to be more
protections
you have to provide more proof
more identification to simply comment at
a school board meeting than to vote
in an election in virginia
as far as they're concerned you know i
as an outside agitator shouldn't be
allowed to show up in virginia and
comment on a school board but uh if i
show up and want to vote there
as far as they're concerned there should
be no way to stop me
so what that means is i'm they've
they've changed the rules to stop me
from commenting at the school board
meeting i'm so i'm not going to be able
to do that but i'll still be there at
the rally
outside
and we're hoping to have a large crowd
so if you're anywhere within the
vicinity doesn't matter if you if you
live in loudoun county or not i
obviously live far away i'm coming
anyway i hope you come as well all right
since we're on the subject of school
board meetings let's play this clip for
you this is a woman this is also
virginia i believe this is i think
fairfax yeah okay
fcps that's fairfax county public
schools in virginia
so many of these videos are from public
schools in virginia
um it's it's a mess in virginia it's not
it's
it's again it's like this in men all
across the country but for whatever
reason
uh virginia is sort of at the tip of the
spear right now
so here's a woman
and we can't
there's a large portion of her
address to the school board that we
can't play because we just have to bleep
the entire thing
so there's no point in playing it
but she is very concerned and angry
about some straight-up pornographic
books
that are available in the library to
students
in fairfax county
and she does talk about that then she
actually reads some passages from the
book that part we had to cut out
but then it's interesting at the end to
hear the way the school board reacts to
her sponsor and what they say listen to
this
the books were available
and we checked them out
both of these books
include pedophilia
sex between men
and boys
both books describe different acts one
book describes a fourth grade boy
performing oral sex on an adult male
the other book has detailed
illustrations
of a man having sex with a boy
the illustrations include
fellatio
sex toys
masturbation
and violent nudity
pedophilia here
this is not an oversight at fairfax high
school
yes
there are children in the audience do
not interrupt my time do not interrupt
my time
i would like to remind everybody stand
here until my time is restored and my
time is finished
these books are in stock and available
in the libraries of robinson for high
school
and annandale high school
pornography is offensive to all people
it is offensive to common decency it is
the reason why the emperor
and then they cut her off now they're
concerned about the the kids man they're
kids here
first of all i'm looking at the footage
right now
i don't see any kids in the audience
i don't know i okay let's see there do
you see any kids anyone see any kids
there
i see adults i see no children
oh but now they're worried about kids
the imaginary invisible children with
invisibility cloaks that are sitting
apparently in the in the audience there
the school board meeting
if there are children there yeah this is
inappropriate but
that's why it shouldn't be in the school
and you got to love how one of the
school board member members corrects her
and says well those are high school
those are for high school students yeah
so like 14 year olds
they're still minors they're still
children
you freak you creep
you degenerate filth
it's it's hard to fully appreciate
because we had to again we had to cut it
you can go and look find that clip
online if you want to
we had to cut out the part where she's
actually reading from it but it is
graphic graphic depictions
of not just descriptions i should say
graphic graphic descriptions of not just
sexual activity
but specifically sexual activity between
young boys and adult men
and these are books that they put
in the school for kids to check out
is there an intentional
uh plan
to normalize pedophilia yes is it in the
school system absolutely
it's time to really wrap our minds
around that that's not a this is not
slippery slope we're not talking about
into the distant future what might
happen in some dystopian vision of the
of the future
it's not a conspiracy theory this is
what they're doing right now
in the school system
so much of what they do in schools
i mean
sex ed itself
the sex ed program modern sex ed pro
what they thought what they call
comprehensive
sex ed in the
schools that is all a plot a plan
to
sexualize children
that's where it comes from that's what
it derives from
[Music]
that's it's
that that is the origin story of
comprehensive sex ed
you know it's why they they have sex ed
classes teaching elementary schoolers
about masturbation and so on
i opened the show a few weeks ago
talking about the the history of um
of the
well-known renowned pervert alfred
kinsey
and even to this day
decades later you know much of what they
teach in sex ed is based on the work of
kinsey
who
was it was a degenerate creep himself
and a pervert
and believed that that children small
children babies were sexual creatures
and that's why he had you know studies
where he where he would give stop
watches to pedophiles
and have them go rape babies
and time
time it and then fill out a chart to
tell us how many
alleged orgasms the babies had
um
and that was his that was his great work
that he that he contributed to society
in his book the sexual behavior in the
human mail
still is the kinsey institute
still around today
widely respected as well
all of our modern sex ed traces back to
him
and that's what he wanted to do
that was his belief that children are
are sexual
and that no sexual behavior is immoral
that there is that that's that's
sexuality is an amoral
arena
any attempt to impose any kind of
morality on any sexual behavior was
wrong was
ironically immoral by his
by his way of thinking
so that's where it comes from going back
decades and so we should not be
surprised
to see this sort of thing
all right we're also not surprised to
see this anymore from the daily wire
melbourne police fired rubber bullets
into a crowd and we have some footage of
this just watch this footage here look
at this
you know
look okay here's here's the crowd
running away
now what is the crowd doing they're just
pro they're protesting peacefully
protesting
and you can hear look listen to that
here's the police chasing down these
protesters and shooting at them shooting
them in the back with rubber bullets as
they run away
my god
this is happening in australia
reading from the daily wires melbourne
police fired rubber bullets into a crowd
and arrested more than 200 people during
the third straight day of anti-lockdown
in australia's second largest city which
is trying to maintain strict state home
orders to control the spread of coven
19.
australia has adopted some of the
strictest anti-covet measures in the
world in an attempt to reach covet zero
or a full period without a single covet
19 infection
um
and we've seen i mean every day we have
more footage out of australia to see
what
see what sort of measures they're
having to put in place what policies
they're putting in place what they're
having to do in order to achieve this
dream of covet zero which will never
ever happen and they know that
that will never happen and even if it
does
it's going to be temporary
covet 19 is
like the flu in that
it is endemic
it's it's in the world now it's never
going away
and so what they're saying in australia
is that we have to shut the entire
continent down
and you can't leave your home as long as
there is one cova case that's the policy
if there is one one coveted case
anywhere on the continent
the whole society shuts down
the fact that we can't
even agree in this country
that that is an insane suicidal policy
we can't even agree that it's maybe a
mild overreaction
that's what scares me the most i mean i
feel bad for the people in australia
i'm also grateful i don't live there
and i'll tell you one thing if i was a a
uh
more of the of the sort of
interventionist sort
then i think i'd be calling for us to
invade australia
and
take it over by force
and
unseat their oppressive regime
now at this point we're we're in we're
in no position to really judge any other
countries
and the kind of you know or or any other
government any other regimes and the
impression that they inflict on uh
oppression they inflict on their people
because that's about as bad as it gets
telling people they can't leave their
home
i mean you've removed all basic human
freedom and liberty from them all of it
it's all gone it's all out the window
i mean in australia right now you have
zero freedom
and the really scary thing is that in
this country there is an appetite for
that
there are people who there are people
who look at that
if you can imagine it who look at that
video footage we just played and they
look at it longingly with envy
and they say oh man i wish they would do
that here
the only thing right now
preventing it from getting that bad here
and i don't know how long it's going to
last the only thing preventing it
is that we have gun rights in this
country we have a second amendment and
they don't in australia
right now the government assumes they
wouldn't be able to get away with this
i don't know if they're right or not
they couldn't get away with it
all right from the post-millennial says
two evacuees from afghanistan will face
federal charges for crimes allegedly
committed at fort mcgoy mccoy
barula nouri
20 is charged with attempting to engage
in a sexual act with a minor
through the use of force
the victim was not yet 16 years old
muhammad haroon imad 32
is charged with assaulting his spouse by
strangling and suffocating her
the indictment alleges that the assault
occurred on september 7th 2021
both men made initial appearances of
madison uh on september 16th that are
being
detained at the dane county jail
um
so i mean we we evacuated all these
afghans from the country
you know by the plane load
and we were told that there was going to
be a process
right a screening process that's what
the bite administration promised us
oh we're not just going to bring anyone
over here we're going to screen them
well it's only been about a month and
already we have at least two rapists
in the crowd
not not a not a huge surprise
when you just bring plane loads of
people over from another country
a lot you know a lot of young men young
single men
and especially from a culture
where
sexual violence
is normalized
you know sex between adult men and boys
there are people in this country who
want to normalize it as we just went
over
but in afghanistan
that's a normal part of the culture
that's something that our
you know that our military for the 20
years they spent in afghanistan
and if you talk to pretty much any
veteran who spent any amount of time
stationed in afghanistan they'll they'll
tell you the horrifying stories
and one of the most horrifying things
about it is that they would see this
going on
these these uh boys being raped and they
weren't allowed to do anything about it
so this is a feature of the culture over
there
and then you take a bunch of men from
that culture and you bring them over
here
i don't think we can be too surprised
by what happens all right let's see
what else do we have here um
let's see do we want to do this if i can
find it
all right it's also from the daily wire
it says in an op-ed condemning a
pro-life law in texas as a human rights
crisis for american women actress uma
thurman reveals that she once had an
abortion calling it her darkest secret
thurman admits in the op-ed that she
wanted to keep her child though she felt
abortion was her only option
after speaking with her family
the decision to have an abortion and
kill the baby left her heart broken and
still causes her pain today
um
the actress admits the abortion caused
her anguish that saddens me even now
but added that abortion allowed her the
path to the life full of joy and love
that i have experienced
and the op-ed closed with thurman
condemning texas pro-life legislation
which bans abortion after the unborns
heartbeat is detectable so if we find
yet again this cognitive dissonance on
the pro-abortion side especially with
women on the pro-abortion side who've
had abortions
and we've heard the same thing we've
heard this kind of confession admission
from plenty of female celebrities
especially the last few weeks talking
about their own abortions
and most of the time they'll tell you
that it was
heartbreaking it was tragic anguish i
mean she uses the word think about what
anguish is it's caused her anguish
and yet while she is dealing with a
broken heart
and tragedy
and guilt and anguish by her own
admission
it has also allowed her to live a life
of joy
now i don't know about you but i don't
know that you can have a life full full
of joy
that also prominently incorporates
anguish
and heartbreak
um
and yet while
while saying all of these things about
abortion how it's heartbreaking and it
causes anguish
she is still a proponent of abortion
she still considers it an attack on
women if you
don't allow them to have abortions
well we have to ask the same question
yet again but
if it was heartbreaking
and caused you anguish
and you consider it a tragic choice that
you had to make
um why
what's so heartbreaking about it
taking a lifeless clump of cells
something that is nothing more than
basically a
parasite or cancerous growth a tumor
which is how the pro-abortion side talks
about quote-unquote fetuses
getting rid of something like that i
mean does anyone
i don't know anyone who's ever had um
tape worms
and taken medicine to get rid of the
tapeworms do they consider that in uh
anguished do they have anguish over that
is that a heartbreaking decision
the doctor comes in and says hey you've
got parasites in your intestines we got
to give you this medicine to get rid of
them
are you are you having any moment of
anguish
trying to decide
years later are you writing op-eds about
how terrible and tragic it was
if you have a cancerous growth on your
body that you have to remove
and and and dispose of it is that is
that going to cause you anguish is that
heartbreaking
no the anguish and the heartbreak which
i do believe she has suffered
in fact if anything she's she's
downplaying it
that comes from the from the innate
recognition that she has
that this was a child this was a human
life
and that as much as she wants to think
that through abortion she just kind of
reset the clock and went back to
being a child-free woman
um in reality she that child is her
child and now it's a dead child she's
the mother of a dead child and she
recognizes that
but she doesn't have the moral courage
to take that all the way to its
conclusion
and to say you know what
this was a child this is a human being
killing children is a horrible thing
that's why i feel so horrible about it
even now years later
we should not be doing this this
shouldn't be allowed she doesn't have
the moral courage to say that all right
i'm going to play um
maybe lighten the mood a little bit
although this is still a very important
subject
here's a a clip from inside edition that
went viral yesterday online and i assume
this is you know a couple years old
because it's
this is on public transportation no
one's wearing a mask so i assume this is
for a couple years old but for whatever
reason it's making the rounds on the
internet now
and uh here's someone from inside is a
reporter
shaming people on camera for their rude
behavior on the subway let's watch
and on this packed standing room only
train hi there how are you this guy had
the nerve to put his luggage on the seat
opposite him this is a completely packed
train and you're hogging a seat with a
pizza which you could certainly share
and a piece of luggage why would you do
that
i just put it there when i got here
nobody asked me to move it so i did why
should somebody have to ask you to move
a piece of luggage when this place is
completely packed there's room up above
why don't you put your bag up here see
all these people that put their bags up
above that's so that somebody else can
sit in a seat okay
why don't you do that sure thing
i'd be happy to help you right now let's
do it
[Music]
ma'am would you like to sit down
who would like to see i would love come
on thank you very much of course so kind
of you lots of people didn't think twice
about putting dirty shoes on seats we're
doing a story about rude commuters and
some nasty things that they do and i
accept that because i don't give a [ __ ]
about anybody else you don't no not
really why would nobody else cares
i i'm i fully am in support of this kind
of thing i'd like to see more of it
certainly i would like to see someone
whether it's inside edition or anybody
else with cameras outside of
you know a target or a walmart or any
grocery store shaming people who ditch
their shopping carts in the middle of
the parking lot that kind of thing
it is a little bit self-aggrandizing on
the part of the reporter so i do have
questions about
you know i i want to know about her
behavior on the subway i want to make
sure that it's i i shame people all the
time for not putting their cards back
but i make sure to do it myself
i i'm fully aware that if you ever if
anyone ever spotted me
ditching a cart in a parking lot it
would be it would be a major scandal for
me and it would bring me great shame
in fact as far as i'm concerned i would
lose all credibility you should stop if
you ever catch me doing that you should
stop watching this show
because i lose all moral credibility in
that moment so i have questions about
this woman does she does she live by
her own code here but um putting that
aside
it is true and and you you experience
this anytime
you're in any kind of public
transportation setting
um
it's it's worse in public transportation
but it's only a symptom of the problem
in the broader culture which is
total lack of decorum
of common courtesy decency
chivalry all that stuff is out the
window
but of course what they're not going to
do on inside edition
is they're not going to ask the question
of
why
has decorum gone out the window
why don't people care about basic
courtesy and respect anymore
i mean why are there men
sitting down on the train when there are
women standing
why is that the case
because then you go deeper into the to
the
into the
cultural rot that all this stuff springs
from
feminism has a lot to do with that
big reason why there's you know a big
reason why there's women standing in
men's sitting feminism which rejec which
rejects chivalry
rejects the idea that men have any
special duty to
women in that way
so that's part of the conversation they
don't want to talk about that so instead
we're just dealing with you know
we're dealing with the rotten fruit but
we're not getting down to the roots to
figure out where this stuff springs from
that's the problem all right let's get
now to reading the comments
rocking polka dotted flannel shirts
without shame
do you know their name
they're the sweet baby gang
so nick porter says about matt's kids
online statement lower functioning
autistic kids shouldn't be given a
device at all look at the drama they
start on discord and youtube these kids
will literally threaten to kill others
just for saying they don't like dora or
something uh well
what you're missing here nick is it's
not about having autism or learning
disabilities
this is
this is the case for all kids
that all kids lack the proper emotional
development to be on a public stage the
internet is a public stage
and you're
putting yourself out there in front of
potentially millions of people
and you're putting things out there that
will be out there for i mean you're
saying things you're posting things and
those things are gonna be there forever
um
and you're also interacting with uh with
thousands of
of different people on this stage
many adults clearly lack the emotional
development
to be in that environment and comport
themselves well
kids
certainly lack that emotion the only
difference between the kids and the
adult in this situation is that the kids
have an excuse
for their lack of of maturity
you know it's natural
for kids to be immature it's not natural
for adults though so many adults are now
but that's the case for all kids i mean
that's why we should keep all kids away
from the internet as much as possible
uh nell says matt my son had a 24-hour
stomach bug and the school needed a
negative covet test before he could
return to school he had to miss school
to wait for the results even though he
felt
fine yeah that's bad enough but now i
mean
a stomach bug you would expect a kid at
least would miss school for a day
but now what are you supposed to do if
your kid
is coughing a little bit in the morning
doesn't you know it doesn't have a fever
it's a little bit of a cough you gotta
keep them home i guess
and anything less than perfect health
you gotta keep them home home keep them
home from school
um
peggy says matt i need a warning for
when the sweet baby gang anthem comes on
because it's too catchy and it's in my
head all the time
i'm even having trouble sleeping
what is this psychological manipulation
you're doing like the spg leader will
ever admit to it yeah you're having
trouble sleeping that's that's part of
the indoctrination into the cult
that's a crucial part of it
i'm breaking you down psychologically
i'm breaking your will
uh venice says
i'm not so bothered about hollywood
adding stuff to the gospels
just as long as they don't take out the
car chase from nativity story
well we're in agreement there a couple a
couple action-packed scenes in the
nativity story
nick says hey matt since you've been
grilling bad republican governors i was
wondering how you feel about ohio
governor mike dewine
he had a mask mandate up until july and
has tried to put in another but the
legislature won't let him thanks love
the show
uh
i haven't followed
the ohio governor that closely
but if that's the case and you live in
ohio then you've got to deal with that
come election time
what i'll say is i you know i'm aware of
a
a very small number of republican
governors
who i have any respect for at this point
i mean there's only one that comes
immediately to mine there might be a few
others that i'm not thinking of right
now and not just republican governors
but republican politicians on the
national stage at all
is mike dewine in that group probably
not
um richard says as a brit i'd like to
apologize to our american cousins
american cousins for james corden
seriously we had no idea he'd make it in
your country that said we're just glad
to see the back of him
yeah well i appreciate your apology but
j when it comes to late night hosts
it's so bad right now the landscape is
so bad that james corden isn't even
he's he's he's if we start to if we were
listing the least funny and most
annoying he does he's not he's not even
in like the top three that's how bad it
is
but your apologies are still very much
appreciated you know i am a
coffee addict from way back in the day
and uh the problem is i had this problem
even before i had kids i was drinking
way too much coffee to give me
energy and endurance throughout the day
and then now i have four kids and uh so
now i'm relying on it even more but the
problem is no matter how much that stuff
you drink it's not good for you to drink
too much
and uh you're still not gonna have all
the energy you need and that's why uh
it's so nice to introduce to you a new
way to start your day super beets heart
chews they're a tasty treat i mean these
things are delicious and they give you
the energy you need and are they're good
for you as well no more afternoon
coffees energy drinks and candy for a
quick pick-me-up add two delicious
plant-based super beets heart shoes to
your morning routine and promote
heart-healthy energy for your day
without a caffeine
crash the grape seed extract used in
superb heart shoes has been clinically
shown to be two times as effective as
supporting normal blood pressure as a
healthy lifestyle alone
and i tell you i mean it's they give you
the the portions you're supposed to eat
but i had to stop myself from eating the
whole bag because they are that tasty
um join over 1 million customers get
free shipping and returns a 90-day
money-back guarantee and right now you
can get a 30-day supply with your first
purchase at superbeats.com welsh
superbeats.com walsh and also
you deserve to wake up to the facts
while you're chewing on your super beats
heart shoes which is why we started our
newest podcast morning wire which has
been topping the apple on spotify charts
since its recent release it's the only
daily news podcast that value your time
and the truth and while we're working
overtime to bring you the news you need
to know we need your help to bring the
facts trending towards number one so
subscribe and start listening now to
morning wire on apple spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts and
leave a five star review if you like
what you hear now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
so today for the cancellation i think my
job is pretty easy i need only pass
the cancellation mic the baton to an
unnamed woman
as yet unnamed on the subway who um
different subway from the inside edition
thing
who took matters into her own hands to
cancel a disgusting pornographic ad
campaign by the dating app okay cupid
okcupid has littered subways and other
areas in many major cities with posters
and billboards
advertising and services with messages
declaring that okcupid is for every
single pansexual
every single non-monogamist
every single vaxxer and there's a
close-up picture of two people french
kissing with their tongues apparently
melded together there it is you can see
that
every single tree hugger with a picture
of a half naked guy with a potted plant
shoved on his underwear
they've also plastered signs that say
things like
it's okay to have strong convictions and
abandon them for a night
and it's okay to only date someone who's
pro-choice and many other messages in
that vein
while this woman on the train decided
that
she didn't approve of this campaign and
was worried that children would see it
and be influenced by it so she responded
by going through the train and simply
tearing all the posters down herself
pretty great stuff check it out
i don't know for kids to be looking at
this is that okay
no it's not it's wrong this is
propaganda yeah this is normalizing
normalizing the next generation is
decent
yeah so i know like no one sees us no
this is disgusting because tv told them
not to get that not to get upset
in congress
thank you
beautiful sight to behold there not the
posters but
this woman doing what needs to be done
this is of course exactly the correct
response to the insane filth that's
shoved down our throats and our kids
throats everywhere we go
the correct response is not
tolerance it's not politeness it's not
to be passive or nonchalant
it's not to transcribe all of our
grievances in an email
and fired off to okcupid customer
service center just so they can ignore
it or rather gather around on their
lunch break and laugh at it
the right approach is to remove the
filth yourself
intolerance for it intolerance is a
virtue
one of the biggest mistakes we ever made
in this culture and as conservatives
is to believe the lie
that tolerance is is is a universal
virtue that it's a universal good
and that you're somehow a good person
that how good you are as a person can be
judged by your capacity to put up with
things
man that's an easy virtue tolerance
the great thing about the the so-called
virtue of tolerance is that you can be a
virtuous person while laying on your
couch eating doritos
because when you do that you're
tolerating everything
when you see something bad happening and
you look the other way that's tolerant
you're being tolerant
so it's a great virtue for cowards and
lazy people
and that's why it's not a real virtue at
all
she's displaying
righteous intolerance here by removing
it now they could go and put up the
filth again sure but then you know we
should just take it down again
back and forth back and forth until they
get the message
that's what the other side would do
and has done
the only question is whether we want to
continue abiding by rules that they
don't abide by
they see something they don't like and
they just say i'll just take it down
that's it i'll take it down
even if it's a
150 year old statue
i'll get a crowd of people we'll we'll
take we'll use some straps and we'll
just we'll pull the thing down
should we handicap ourselves with this
weird notion of decorum i mean there's
there's appropriate times for decorum i
think this is an inappropriate time
should we do that while the other side
rides through the land doing as they
please
now of course you might argue that this
is not a matter of mere decorum perhaps
this is a matter of rights you might say
in fact i've i've seen people on the
right
make this argument in response to this
heroic woman in the subway the subway
avenger as i have just now decided to
call her they said that okcupid has
private property rights and free speech
rights
and that this woman has infringed on the
rights of the
poor degenerates over at okcupid by
behaving in this way
today to that i think there are two
responses
first one is
even if that's true who cares
but second it's not true
you don't have any fundamental right to
plaster filth and degeneracy in public
areas
you don't have any fundamental right
to flood society with this kind of
sewage
you have the legal right yes nobody
disputes that i mean there's no question
that this woman committed a crime at
least vandalism i mean at least a
misdemeanor
according to the law no doubt about that
but then again
uh and and if she's charged with a crime
and faces any legal trouble then i'll
want to know where her gofundme is so i
can donate to it and also post it and
get more people to donate to it but
but then again in most states except
texas
there's also no question that doctors
who kill children in the womb have not
committed a crime according to the law
does that mean they have an actual
fundamental human right to do what
they're doing
no
because while legal rights are granted
by the government
human rights actual rights upon which
our legal rights are supposed to be
based
are granted by god
if they're not granted by god then the
concept of human rights makes no sense
it has no meaning
the people who first developed the
concept of human rights certainly
thought that they were derived from the
creator
if they were wrong about that
then they were probably wrong about
human rights existing at all
in which case our legal rights are
entirely arbitrary and you have no deep
moral calling to respect them if we have
no fundamental god-given human rights
then when we talk about rights we just
mean
this is what the government says the
people in charge of the government right
now say this is what you can do this is
what you can't do
and you might respect that because
you're afraid of because they use force
and you're afraid of the force they
might use on you if you don't respect it
but there's no deeper
moral obligation to respect it
because it's arbitrary
but if rights are derived from god
then the question is whether god
desires for okay cupid to promote
pansexuality
and non-monogamy and pornography on the
subway
the question really would boil it down
to this is
whose side do you think god is on
the people who put those posters up
or the woman who tore him down
i think the answer to that question
is is very clear and we need to start
thinking about things in these terms
we know what the government says
we also know who's in charge of the
government
you know we know what the ruling class
is all about
um
we know what they say our our rights are
and our rights aren't
but where do these rights actually
derive from
who who's whose authority are we are we
in the end going to ultimately respect
god's authority or the government's
authority
and that's why today i rather than
canceling that woman i join her in
canceling okcupid which she has already
done such a fantastic job of doing
and we'll leave it there for today on
you know i don't know if i called a
positive note as positive as you're
going to get on this show so thanks for
watching have a great day and a great
weekend godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover
our technical directors austin stevens
production manager pavovsky the show is
edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin